THEY DIDN'T MEAN THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE VIOLENT.
AND NOW JOINING ME IS THE WHITE
FLAG PODCAST, AND ALSO MOLLY
WALSH FROM THE DAILY BEAST.
AND NOW, MIKE PENCE IS FINALLY
SPEAKING THE TRUTH 13 MONTHS
AFTER THE FACT.
I GUESS BETTER LATE THAN NEVER,
BUT HOW IMPORTANT WAS THAT TO
HEAR THOSE WORDS FROM MIKE
PENCE?
>> I'M NOT SURE, BUT PENCE IS
RIGHT AND TRUMP IS WRONG.
BUT HERE IS THE BIGGER DEAL.
MIKE PENCE HAS ABSOLUTELY NO
SHOT AT THE REPUBLICAN
NOMINATION IN 2024, AND IF
DONALD TRUMP WANTS THE
NOMINATION IN '24, IT IS HIS,
BECAUSE THE SAD TRUTH, JIM, IS
THIS THING IS OVER.
THERE IS NO, THERE IS NO FIGHT
FOR THE SOUL OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
IT IS TRUMP'S PARTY, AND THE
PARTY OF TRUMPISM, AND YOU
MENTIONED THE CENSURING OF
KINZINGER AND CHENEY, AND WHO
SPOKE UP TO DEFEND KINZINGER AND
CHENEY, AND WHERE WAS MIKE PENCE
AND TED CRUZ AND RON DESANTIS,
AND ANY REPUBLICAN WHO WANTS TO
RUN FOR PRESIDENT?
THIS PARTY CANNOT BE SAVED.
>> YEAH, MOLLY, YOU KNOW, MIKE
PENCE, AND HE JUST TOLD THE
TRUTH.
THAT IS WHAT HE DID YESTERDAY
INSTEAD OF KOWTOWING TO TRUMP,
AND HE STATED A FACT THAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT CANNOT DO THIS.
BUT TRUMP HAS GONE AFTER PENCE
AT EVERY TURN FOR FAILING TO
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
LET'S LISTEN TO THIS.
>> MIKE PENCE, I WILL TELL YOU
RIGHT NOW, I'M NOT HEARING GOOD
STORIES.
>> I ONLY WISH THAT MY FRIEND
MIKE PENCE HAD THAT ADDITIONAL
COURAGE TO SEND, TO SEND THE
RESULTS BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE.
>> IT WAS VERY SAD WHEN MIKE
PENCE GAVE THOSE VOTES OVER.
>> I THINK THAT MIKE HAS BEEN
SADLY HURT WITH WHAT TOOK PLACE
WITH RESPECT TO JANUARY 6th.
I THINK THAT HE HAS BEEN
MORTALLY WOUNDED FRANKLY,
BECAUSE I SEE THE REACTION THAT
HE IS GETTING FROM PEOPLE, AND
WHY DIDN'T HE JUST HAND IT BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE.
>> HOLLY, PENCE CLEARLY WANTS TO
BE PRESIDENT ONE DAY, BUT IT
TOOK HIM 13 MONTHS TO STATE THE
OBVIOUS.
>> YEAH, PENCE IS LIKE A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS WHO KNOW BETTER, A
LOT, AND REFUSE TO DISAVOW TRUMP
BECAUSE OF THE TWITTER, BUT
THERE IS NO TWITTER AND NOW
AFRAID OF PRIMARY CHALLENGES.
BUT AT EVERY POINT THE
REPUBLICANS HAVE HAD EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO DISAVOW TRUMPISM,
AND GO FOR DEMOCRACY AND SAY
THAT IT MUST BE PROTECTED AND
THIS PERSON IS ANTI-DEMOCRATIC,
AND AT EVERY POINT THEY HAVE
EITHER SAID NOTHING OR, YOU
KNOW, TACITLY KIND OF ENCOURAGED
HIM.
SO WE ARE GETTING TO THE POINT
NOW WHERE SO MUCH OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IS DOUBLED DOWN
ON THIS ANTI-DEMOCRATIC,
ANTI-YOU KNOW, VOTER, PRO VOTER
SUPPRESSION, AND ANTI-COUNT THE
VOTE KIND OF THING THAT WE ARE
IN AN IMPOSSIBLE SITUATION.
YOU CAN'T HAVE ONE PARTY WHO
BELIEVES IN THE CENTRAL TENET OF
AMERICAN DEMOCRACY, AND SO IT IS
GOOD THAT MIKE PENCE SAID THIS,
AND CERTAINLY HE IS SEEING WHAT
WAY THE WIND IS BLOWING, AND SO
MAYBE THERE IS SOMETHING TO
THAT, BUT IT IS WAY, WAY, WAY
TOO LATE, AND AT THIS POINT, I
MEAN, I DON'T EVEN THINK IT IS
CLEAR TO ME THAT YOU NEED, YOU
KNOW, THE BIG GUNS, AND YOU NEED
EVERYONE OUT THERE SAYING THAT
OR ELSE IT IS TOO LITTLE TOO
LATE.
>> YEAH, AND THE WIND IS NOT
SEEMING TO BLOW IN THE DIRECTION
OF DEMOCRACY INSIDE OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, JOE.
AND LET'S PLAY HOW THE FORMER
CHIEF STRATEGIST STEVE BANNON
REACTED TO THE PENCE SPEECH.
>> YOU WILL CARRY THIS THING
EVENTUALLY TO YOUR GRAVE,
BECAUSE IT IS A MARK OF SHAME,
AND YOU A STONE COLD COWARD,
BORIS EPSTEIN, AND WE WILL TALK
ABOUT THIS THING THAT BROKE THIS
AFTERNOON AND BORIS, YOU HAVE TO
HELP ME OUT HERE, BECAUSE I
CAN'T TAKE PENCE AND I CAN'T
TAKE PENCE AND MARK SHORT AND
ALL OF THESE GUYS OUT THERE
RATTING OUT TRUMP UP ON CAPITOL
HILL RIGHT NOW.
>> YEAH, JOE, BANNON IS SAYING
THAT HE IS GOING TO CARRY IT TO
THE GRAVE, AND THOSE ARE CODE
WORDS, AND THAT IS ESSENTIALLY A
THREAT, IT IS NOT?
>> IT IS A DIRECT THREAT, JIM,
BUT HERE'S WHAT EVERYBODY
LISTENING TO YOU AND I NEED TO
UNDERSTAND RIGHT NOW.
STEVE BANNON SPEAKS RIGHT THERE
FOR THE REPUBLICAN PARTY BASE.
THE HARD CORE REPUBLICAN PARTY
VOTERS ARE WITH BANNON AND NOT
PENCE.
YOU DO A GREAT JOB OF TRYING TO
WAKE UP THE COUNTRY, BUT THIS
ELECTION YEAR, JIM, MAN, WE HAVE
TO WAKE EVERYBODY UP TO THIS
REALIZATION THAT THIS PARTY IS
MORE BANNON THAN PENCE, AND THEY
ARE ON TRACK RIGHT NOW TO TAKE
CONTROL AGAIN IN 2022 IF THE
REST OF AMERICA DOESN'T WAKE UP
AND GET OFF THEIR ASS AND GET
OUT AND VOTE.
>> YEAH, I MEAN, STEVE BANNON IS
THE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY, AND SO THIS IS
ALL ON THE SAME DAY, MOLLY, THAT
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY VOTED TO
CENSURE ADAM KINZINGER AND LIZ
CHENEY, AND THIS IS ALL IN THE
DEMOCRATIC-LED LEGITIMATE
DISCOURSE OF WHICH CHENEY
RESPONDED OF THE RIOTERS THAT
THIS IS JANUARY 6th, AND THIS IS
NOT LEGITIMATE POLITICAL
DISCOURSE, AND THE RNC IS SAYING
THAT NOT PEOPLE INVOLVED IN
VIOLENCE, BUT THEY DIDN'T GET IT
RIGHT THE FIRST TIME, AND IT IS
SOUNDING LIKE CLEANUP ON AISLE
6, AND IT IS PATHETIC.
>> YEAH.
I MEAN, THEY REALLY MADE THE
WRONG CHOICE, BUT CONTINUOUSLY
FOR THE LAST 13 MONTHS, THEY
HAVE MADE THE WRONG CHOICE, AND
PROTECTED DONALD TRUMP, AND
REFUSED TO DISAVOW POLITICAL
VIOLENCE WHICH IS AN EASY ONE,
AND IT IS HARD TO WATCH, AND YOU
CAN SEE ULTIMATELY THAT THE BASE
HAS MOVED FURTHER TO THE RIGHT,
AND FURTHER AGAINST DEMOCRACY,
TOO.
IT IS JUST REALLY A SORT OF
UNBELIEVABLE THING TO WATCH.
AND 13 MONTHS AGO IF THESE
PEOPLE HAD SAID POLITICAL
VIOLENCE IS WRONG, AND DEMOCRACY
IS RIGHT, AND THIS IS WHAT WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON, WE'D BE IN A
DIFFERENT POSITION TODAY.
>> AND JOE, KEVIN McCARTHY
REFUSED TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
ABOUT THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE,
AND SO WHAT IS GOING ON UP
THERE, BECAUSE YOU SERVED WITH
KEVIN McCARTHY, AND WITH TRUMP,
THERE IS NO BOTTOM?
>> JIM, I DID SERVE WITH
McCARTHY, AND HE IS A HOLLOW
MAN.
HE HAS NO CORE.
ALL HE GIVES A DAMN ABOUT RIGHT
NOW IS THAT HE WANTS TO BE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
HE DOESN'T CARE ABOUT THE
COUNTRY, AND HE DOES NOT CARE
ABOUT THE STATE OF THE COUNTRY,
BUT HE WANTS TO BE SPEAKER.
AGAIN, THE REPUBLICAN SILENCE,
AND KINZINGER, AND CHENEY ARE
CENSURED FOR PURSUING THE TRUTH
ABOUT AN INSURRECTION, AND ALL
OF THE REPUBLICAN OFFICIALS
DON'T SAY A DAMN THING, AND THAT
IS WHERE THE PARTY IS RIGHT NOW.
>> MOLLY, A FINAL THOUGHT FROM
YOU, BECAUSE MY THOUGHT
YESTERDAY WAS THAT THE RNC
SHOULD BE CENSURING MARGIE
TAYLOR GREEN AND -- SORRY,
CENSURING PEOPLE LIKE MARGIE
TAYLOR GREEN AND MADISON
CAWTHORN AND NOT ADAM KINZINGER
AND LIZ CHENEY.
IT DOES NOT MAKE SENSE.
>> THEY CARE ABOUT THE
SMALL-DONOR DONATION, AND PEOPLE
LIKE MARJORIE TAYLOR GREENE ARE
CELEBRATED AND ADAM KINZINGER
AND LIZ CHENEY ARE CENSURED.
>> BUT IT MAKES SENSE, BECAUSE
THAT IS WHERE THE VOTERS ARE.
>> AND PEO